sometimes watching a movie isn't enough
you also want to eat that movie that's
why there's movie recipes today we're
with Chef Mike Isabella at Katniss in
Washington DC we have challenged him
with making a dish fit for prison the
prison wise guys are accustomed to chef
Isabella has prepared a list of
essential ingredients to do just that
they are tomato sauce I'll put too many
onions in the sauce pigs feet the chumps
who live like pigs in the joint and
meatballs for spider because she's got a
lot of compose let's break some good
cooking
good fella good fella I'm so excited
about this this is one of the best
movies of all time it really is and you
tell me you're gonna cook me a dish on
Good Fellas I'm expecting blood and
cocaine mm-hmm Yeah right sure why not
and I'm never done cocaine mm-hmm but
well if Mike Isabella mated you and you
were definitely out anything that guy
brought me
so this movie also has is famous for
that gorgeous one shot yeah where they
go into the club probably my favorite
see between that and the helicopter
chase scene just two of the most I just
like to sit and steep in those scenes
right apparently that was just derived
from the fact that they couldn't go
through the front of the of the building
and so like Scorsese just sort of
imagine the shot and I read that it took
eight takes I'm sure that took I stir
that with still a lot like you know
considering all the different things
they had to go on in that shot but but
that's just amazing stuff like that's
legendary I mean that knew that moment
is magic yeah you talked to film nerds
about one shots and that's always in the
conversation and it was it was a plan B
yeah right like a fluke reason created
this magic what would what with that
shot of Ben if my restaurant had said
okay go ahead come as you know I'm go to
the front that's know we would be robbed
of that yes it's amazing to be yeah
thinking on the fly really period of
people can sometimes make better stuff
than they can planning years in advance
yeah it's just amazing
how many times do you think you've seen
Goodfellas at least 30 yeah
me and a co-worker and movie-theater
used to quote this movie all the time we
always be like you know like wait that's
nuts Jimmy is like Jimmy is being an
unconscionable ballbreaker and all those
are so I planned this caper for five
years we as I said you know well that's
just a dip damn damn damn damn yeah what
can I do I am I had to go back and get
her hat no I'm gonna go get the papers
get the papers you know and just like
you know all that stuff we used to like
just quote this movie over and over
again
Oh
oh geez
this looks so good so this is gravy as
we call it from New Jersey Italian this
is this is like kind of like the
difference being tomato sauce and gravy
is we had meat to it so this is usually
served with pasta sometimes on Sundays
but we call sunday gravy so you have
meatballs sausage a little bit of pigs
feet cooked down in there some pork but
lots of tomatoes herbs and then on top I
cried like a little fried grab a lot of
grab a lot of use like parsley and
garlic and lemon
so I fried it all up to make it crispy
to garnish it on top and then I have
some nice fresh grilled garlic bread Wow
when suggested uh Parmesan cheese
this is just what I grew up eating every
Sunday oh my god well then I'm gonna
enjoy it
yes I'm taking the spoon and you're just
gonna have to wait all right that's by
the way that's the best looking garlic
bread I've ever seen oh man all right
Chris you can have some that I mean here
just the smell alone I know
Mel's I know that I'm going to enjoy
amazing
yes cooks for like three hours oh wow
and I do love a good meatball
I probably shouldn't have said that
that's gonna look what you did
yeah now that's not a serving spoon is
getting a berry that night is amazing
what kind of musing this meatball it's a
beef pork and veal different different
different textures of meat different
flavor profiles different fat contents
feels a lighter part the beefs you know
strong flavor the pork is that fatty
fattiness and richness he kind of mix
them all together and we hand mixing
them and then just roll them out and
sear them off and pop them with a grave
and let them go for hours man
I mean it's just everything is so good
and this is just there's so many like I
mean there's so many things working
together that's right so I slice slice
the garlic with the razor today because
you know Goodfellows is is one of my
favorite movies my god
it's one of my famous when they're the
jail cell Italians were there and then
we get all that meat snuck in and
they're bred in and they will make
garlic bread and gravy
and and the Italian if the Italian guys
were slicing it but with a raise because
they couldn't have knives in prison but
they wanted it nice and thin yeah so
today for you I sliced it with a razor
that's all yeah that is a commitment to
this perfect we've talked about that
barry sheene we did I love the attention
to detail in that same you know it's
just yeah you know that you know you're
like man I actually really want this
jail food well you know what I love is
that they're in prison mm-hmm but
they're still like we're gonna do this
right we're gonna do the techniques
right where I take the hard time and let
it cook like if I was in prison I just
give me a piece of bread like but
they're so committed to the quality of
the food the Italian culture yeah
the Italian culture food and food is
food is everything in our world
so if Italian food means Olive Garden to
you into the definition
[Music]
thanks to Mike for the incredible
Italian he's a real wise guy when it
comes to cooking so make sure you head
on over to the community table channel
to learn more from him and all the other
chefs we got to hang with thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time on
hoody recipes
[Music]